[Music]
you
holy crap everybody new Game of Thrones
trailer so we got to freak out about
this if you're new to the channel I do
Game of Thrones videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything I'm
even doing a giveaway I'll explain at
the end of the video but this is just
meant to convey who the big forces will
be and I like the way that is implies
that no one is going to be challenging
Jon Snow for leadership in the north
there was a lot of theories that Sansa
might try to do some back dealing she
might get involved with Littlefinger to
try and do CERP Jon Snow's power who
should the north rally behind trueborn
daughter of Ned and Catelyn Stark born
here at Winterfell I'm not honest
bastard on in the south in the simplest
of ways the promo is just saying that no
you know Jon Snow is going to be the
go-to de-facto leader of the north even
though there will be a lot of
politicking it wouldn't be Game of
Thrones if a little finger didn't have
some plan so we can talk about him in
another bonus video but the really fun
part about the Daenerys promo is that
she's walking through Dragonstone and
sits on the throne there was a lot of
behind the scenes as they were filming
this earlier this year and she has her
new costume on very regal very Targaryen
looking it's almost like all the
characters in the show are slowly moving
towards darker blacker colors so even
though I'm most excited to get a better
look at the throne room in Dragonstone
because it's a relatively new location
Circe's costume is probably the best
who else is freaking out about
Dragonstone though there are so many
reasons why it's important it's
important historically for Daenerys and
her family in the grand history of
Westeros Aegon the conquerer the
Targaryen family and it just happens to
be rife with dragonglass there was a
funny Stannis line I think it was during
season five when he was talking to
Samwell about dragonglass and he's like
I know all about it it's all over the
place on Dragonstone another glass of
soda I'm told you killed a white Walker
did you guys Oh with the doctor made of
dragonglass
dragonglass what the maesters call
obsidian what it is
we haven't dragons done why would
obsidian kill Worf I don't know
I've been going through all the old
manuscripts hoping to find something and
all I've learned is that the children of
the forest used to hunt with dragonglass
in what a coincidence that it just
happens to be the thing that they need
to fight the fourth big power that they
teased at the end of the promo the night
king so this whole trailer almost winds
up just being a tone poem like freak out
about this freak out about Mad Queen
Cersei because the song that they use
for the trailer sit down next to me is
all about them sitting on their
respective Thrones but it talks about
madness when Cersei is walking by so
it's just a fun Easter Egg for Mad King
Daenerys his father and now Mad Queen
Cersei but I know a lot of people are
also wondering about Mad Queen Daenerys
the book character is just a little bit
different just because the plots been
changed so much the TV show version of
the character is a little more
self-assured some people are really
upset about that because she's still
supposed to be very very young in the
book it'd be like it's a little barely
on a Mormon sat on the Iron Throne and
everybody just assumed that she was a
good leader overnight but changes aside
she is her father's daughter so she does
have fire inside of her it's going to be
fun to watch that play out because
they're hyping up all these people
coming at each other like even though
you probably in your mind have an idea
of how this is all going to go down we
believe that John Snow will treat with
Daenerys they'll form an alliance
eventually the characters have to work
up to that so we're almost back at the
Battle of the five kings again during
book 2 with everybody coming at each
other and you're on Greyjoy doesn't
appear in the trailer but he is king of
the Iron Islands now - so you have Jon
Snow vs. Cersei you have Daenerys versus
Cersei and then now you know implying
that there might be some Jon Snow vs.
Daenerys before they actually meet each
other and find out that they're united
in common cause they have a very special
thing in common in that they're both
Targaryen and then you have the night
King versus everyone I love the way they
pan out from his eyeball - but the
Cersei breath so you might be looking at
that and wondering wait are they trying
to say that the night king is going to
make it down to King's Landing because
that was part of Daenerys his vision she
saw hollowed-out version of the iron
throne room that looked like it had been
covered in snow it could have been ash -
like in the wake of a battle with
Daenerys and her dragons that's coming
in season 7 but really they're implying
that winter has come the night King has
rolled through and destroyed everything
so everything is in tatters because
right after this
an inner vision she goes up to the wall
she steps out on the other side and
everything is white
so really it's all about the night King
but even if you adhere to the
rapid-transit theory of Game of Thrones
like the characters just move around
really fast because they need to move
the story along it would still take the
knight king a long time to march his
army all the way from the wall down to
King's Landing so I think that feels
more like a season a thing so let me
know in the comments what do you think
about the promo and what bonus video do
you want me to do next I was originally
going to do a barest video but because
we got this it raises some questions
about dragon stones and air stuff which
in my mind is a little more exciting but
we can talk about whatever you guys want
to talk about so just let me know in the
comments and there is a new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway going on now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it's for one of the enhanced editions of
the books so I'll post my next game of
Thrones bonus video this weekend just
let me know what you want that to be
about while you wait for that you can
click here for the other teaser trailer
and you can click here for the
spider-man homecoming trailer thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you